herzlich willkommen zu meinen heutigen
video leute ihr seid natürlich wie auch
ich große fans der serie 24 stunden eben
tauschen und meine beste web video
partnerin und lebensmittel
wir haben uns wieder ausführlich
überlegt dass er natürlich auch wieder
mit autos zu tun ihr wird wahrscheinlich
im titel gelesen haben wir tauschen 24
stunden lang einen akt lang unser essen
das ich etwas kelly kelly ist was ich
esse ich will auch bekommen falls sich
erinnert habe ich bei kelly morgens uns
movie getrunken und ich bin an die
nassen und sich dafür so das ist ja wir
machen das selbst mit allen mahlzeiten
des tages kelly für dich gibts jetzt
richie sandwiches ist kein witz seitdem
ich mit der mache ich alles auf dem
grill macht mir sogar morgens tausende
auf dem grill und mid caps haben sich
mega geil an
also hat sie genau die schlechteste
person ausgesucht mit der groß machen
also nicht durch selber kochen doch ich
nur nicht so unbegabt im kochen
ich glaube jetzt geht es noch mal jetzt
muss ich mich wirklich kochen es ist
alles auch eher so eine mischung aus
fertiggericht und doch sagt wie
hinzufügen
ich habe für dich sollen joghurt bauen
jetzt
haferflocken kokosnuss sowieso kalten
ich weiß hat sicher richtig lecker wie
ist die richtige blogger mit unserem
handeln muss und ich bin eine
ernährungsbewusste mensch der
verantwortungsvoll mit seiner ernährung
umgeht anders als ich selbst ich glaube
es ist nicht nur das es ist einfach das
schnellste und einfachste was man sich
irgendwie morgens man kann einfach nicht
auch schon mich sagen sind grillstellen
okay leute wir bereiten jetzt unser
frühstück zu
[Musik]
unser frühstück ist angerichtet es gibt
es künftig nicht mehr als deutlich
gesünder aussieht als käme er endlich
sehen lassen mit dem er gab den ketchup
auf diesen und erlangen ist wirklich
machen
sehr gesund deshalb angenehm warm sind
dass man hier
ich habe extra wichtig für uns wir haben
ungefähr gleich lang gebraucht wird man
hätte das jetzt auch schöne anrichten
kann um ehrlich zu sein ich bin ich so
ein ding t help it blogger mal ein
bisschen insbesondere dass man muss es
mir ein bisschen suspekt leute sowieso
niemanden richtig geil
ja man merkt richtig wie gesundheit die
lage ist wirklich regionen wird das
finde ich richtig gut der tag startet
dann mal ganz gut und lange geht es
eigentlich bei mir die sache ist ich
glaube du wirst dich wahrscheinlich in
einer stunde schlechter fühlen und sich
nach dem frühstück tier ist auch das
allseits bekannte berliner dass du schon
mal an seinem 24 stunden tauscht das
angebliche sehr gesund dass ich das
stück gibt es kaffee dann lass es uns
ausprobieren
nach dem frühstück werde ich glaube ich
fühlen wie ein besserer mensch ich würde
sagen sie erst jetzt erstmal auch sehen
uns beim mittagessen wieder so freunde
ist es zeit fürs mittagessen wir haben
hier schon was vorbereitet ich mache
nämlich meine berühmten tolle serie
ich mag auch nicht gesendet das heißt
mit thunfisch zwiebeln und erst vor
einer woche und ist war als lok
thunfisch es gibt quasi einen kompletten
zu stellen mein ganzes leben an mir
vorbei könnte ich mir sehr gut
vorstellen wirklich eine kleine dumme
sache ich habe die nun und vergessen das
heißt ich muss jetzt schnell auch die
taliban hier der zwischenzeit schon mal
hier essen
du willst kannst du noch was filme und
ich gehe ganz schnell los und kaufen
wichtigste die fertig zutaten nach
beiden zulegen
die sich zu arbeiten ist auch mit liebe
angerichtete macht die sache so schön
man ist was man isst das auge isst so
ist auch meine rahmen kelly was genauso
damit gemacht hast was du hast du dich
also da ist die namen mischungen
fertig das ist jetzt ein bisschen
auseinander gelaufen eigentlich sollte
das meer so kassierte für ein mäßig da
funkelt probiere nicht heim auf schild
ja ist das heiß und schlaf aber so
lecker wir müssen was von dem 1
das ist ja quasi so ganz fremd gelernt
hat dass mal wieder vor 4 minuten
gebraucht genau wie früchte und meine
sache ich dachte schon mal dass meine
sachen schnell gehen aber nicht so nicht
so sein es ist ja jetzt nicht nur deine
leistung das ist nichts für mich das war
nicht mehr jeden tag weil es mir jetzt
unsere klassischen mahlzeiten also das
für mich schon ein bisschen zuschauen zu
müssen so stressig wird sich das aber
gar keine details sondern läuft ihr die
ganze branche aus der nahe sondern
stützt so alles aus was ungesund man gar
nicht wusste ich befreit danach haben
wir nichts geileres an einem heißen tag
folgt das mit wasser aus dem 1
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so gesund wie
das mittel wie das frühstück
[Musik]
so klärte letzte haben wird minute zum
rest so ein bisschen frisch zu lieben
würde überhaupt das presseteam
es ist nicht gesagt dass ich hier gut
leute so wenig für mich so diese
fraktion an der stelle ich mir kommen
würde sagt ja wenn jemand das gute
verhältnis ist auch wenig arbeit aber es
ist sehr natürlich noch frischen kapital
ob die nun anlaufen und dann darfst du
gleich einfach so aufgeben werden wieder
heftig mehr dafür mühe beim kochen und
beim rest des lebens nicht möglich die
videos macht übertrage ich werde ich zu
hektisch mit dessen gleich probiert es
nicht merkt bescheid nach geschmack und
zamalek fresh das kann ich auch nicht
einfach thunfisch zu elster oder status
möbel hielt aber politisch wichtig und
da freue ich mich aber das wetter nicht
so ebnet und ich dachte das schmeckte
immer auch nach fisch mag manchmal nicht
einmal trug zur zeit nicht richtig gut
dass wir heute mal okay dort werden wir
zwischenzeiten video für kelly
aufgenommen dass kommt am sonntag auf
ihrem kanal und jetzt erstmal ein bubble
tea holen bevor es dann auch als arm
gilt
kelly ist oft der hellen seite der macht
nicht mit den dunkeln was kochen ins
licht ich habe jetzt so ein bubble tea
probieren jasmin vier systeme tapioka
schreien ja auch schon lange her ja ja
das klappt in liverpool hull kommt so
bei dem kaum noch posten öfter hier
haben ich hab sogar bei mir um die ecke
ich hatte gerade so ein platz ins
bettchen
ich lasse die gibt es gar nicht mehr
das ding ist ich dachte die wurde
irgendwie vom roten oder ich hab ich bin
überzeugt davon dass ich von damals im
kader von allen gehabt und gehen weil
ich die ein jahren immer aufeinander
geschossen in der schule aber ja ich
muss sagen dass hier ist es wirklich gar
nicht so schlecht als kelly zu essen
bist du zufrieden wir sind überall da ja
einfach wie ich kann mir ganz schön
abend so weit es geht also abendessen
ich habe mir etwas besonderes überlegt
beiden einen gast besten werde ich dir
meine berühmten bürger machen
von ihnen gehören terri was hast du für
mich ich hab ich s pizza okay so nach
einem tag wie heute
auch das ist ein echtes duell stellen
ich müsste mir einfach bestellt einfach
einen pc
ok dann kriege ich was dafür werden mich
so viele leute hassen da draußen weil
manche leute hassen einfach ja das ist
vielleicht nicht so klassisch
italienisch um ehrlich zu sein als ich
meine italienischen austauschschüler da
hatte als ich mein abi gemacht habe
hatte er so gesagt gibt es hier wirklich
pizza hawaii gibt es das oder ist es ist
es so eine geschichte
daraus muss intelligenz gmbh dfki und
ich möchte dass wir jetzt alle kommen
hier ist für dich bitte danke so dann
decke drauf war der bürger steht und es
weiter bürgerstift dann leute geht es an
den finaltisch stelle kriegt man bürger
ich kreiere prinz aber ich hätte jetzt
pizza hawaii wissen würde aber dürfen
bürger noch nie das special sagen dann
gibt es so kein zweites tor kennedy
dollar zu probieren
[Musik]
aber das echt lecker ist die geräte
meist sehr gut dargestellt
beim ersten satz richtig gut ich würde
sagen in diesem sinne hätten wir das
projekt ich war zwar wirklich hinter
sagen ich habe ein paar sachen gewesen
die ich sonst auf jeden fall nicht so
essen wäre kein bariton ich will keine
rahmen essen die pizza
vielleicht werde ich das eine oder
andere auch machen
der ecklohn
wenn ihr noch eine fortsetzung der
tausch sei mit kelly haben wollt dann
schreibt dass jetzt die kommentare wir
haben vielleicht schon ideen und dann
sehen wir zunächst video wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]